ça fait des heures et des heures qu'on
roule sur ces routes de terre et de
sable qui nous mène au site qui est
devenu depuis des décennies
le point de chute officielle des fusées
soyouz ici au kazakhstan donc on est au
coeur des steppes du kazakhstan
c'est qu'on approche du site c'est qu'on
a pu croiser sur le chemin des débris de
vieille fusée soyouz donc cette partie
qui se désintègre lors de l'atterrissage
et les conditions météo comme vous
pouvez le constater sont optimales c'est
un ciel complètement dégagée et bleu et
une température de 38 degrés au sol
c'est chaud pour nous mais seriez sur le
compare aux températures que les
astronautes devront traverser lors de
leur descente durant les moments qui
m'ont pénétré l'atmosphère terrestre on
parle de température de 2000 degrés
celsius pour un bouclier thermique qui
protège la capsule
mais ça sera plus tard ce soir d'ici là
il ya plusieurs joueurs à surveiller
16 heures heure de l'est
les astronautes prendront place à bord
de la ssi use dans leur combinaison
spatiale ils sont trois ensuite quelques
heures plus tard à 19h25 moment très
important la capsule se détache europe
seulement de la station spatiale
internationale
et après avoir passé deux heures en
orbite à s'éloigner de la station bien
la descente commencera on parle d'une
descente qui va durer une heure une
heure des plus intenses d'ailleurs dans
les vélos tour ici les hélicoptères de
secours
les médecins toute l'équipe technique
est sur le qui-vive est prêt à les
sortir les astronautes de rasteau news
une fois qu'elle aura série
l'opération est réglé au quart de tour
l'atterrissage à 22h48 55 secondes
le site amaral correspond radio-canada
dans les steppes du kazakhstan